you talk a bit about your ideological
journey you started off with very
different political beliefs we have now
I start allowed on the left because I
was a kid and it was the 60s and and the
girls on the left would do it it was
that simple really it's okay I remember
my freshman year my Tivo outreach I mean
there were some bookends are looking
what Republicans have to do is have more
sex and then you know a palin is like a
step in the right direction obviously
the Palin family has a fair amount of
sex and not quite as much as David
Letterman thinks they do but you know
nonetheless Dee I was walking down an
alley first first weekend at college my
freshman year I'm walking down an alley
and there's Faridah bars on two sides of
salad one bar is filled with all this
sort of like sorority and fraternity
jock types
good-looking kids beautiful girls and
all dressed up very nicely
and having fun and looking quite
attractive but I'm thinking I'm not
good-looking and I'm not an athlete and
I'm not getting I came for eternity not
getting in it and on the other side of
the alley there was this bar called Mac
and Chavez and out over there there are
equally attractive girls these girls who
Iron their hair and their playing
Kumbaya and the guitar and they're
smoking Lucky Strikes and drinking beer
out of the bottle and I'm thinking well
those girls are very cute too I'll bet
they do it you know I persisted in my
Marxism until I was 22 or 23 and I got a
job I'm a leftist I'm a socialist I I'm
for sharing everything I get a job I get
a job as a messenger in New York $150 a
week get paid every two weeks I'm really
looking forward to that 300 bucks really
looking forward to and so's my landlord
this is more money than I've had in my
hands in a long time I get my paycheck I
net out it like 185 93 after federal tax
and state tax and city tax and Social
Security contribution and retirement
fund which I was very interested in and
that aid and healthcare benefits and all
the stuff in union dues I net out at 1
180 something and I go in a minute I've
been a socialist all these years I've
been screaming for socialism yelling for
socialism demonstrating for social
and I discovered we have socialism they
just took half my pay I'm not
rockefeller my pay that was gentleman
that's what it takes [ __ ]
the journey from easy sex to paycheck
easy sex the paychecks when you were in
the early years of your career you were
sort of in the midst of a rightward turn
in the nation do you think that's over
now
yes yes the public tends to vibrate
between the public loves freedom and it
loves getting things for free you know
you can't I mean you know this is only
human and so politically the public has
a tendency to vibrate between the
benefits of freedom that would be Reagan
and getting things for free
that would be Obama and so they go back
and forth and after they get things for
free for a while they realized there's
actually is a price attached to the
stuff they're getting for free and the
price can be quite high the price can be
like living in the Carter Administration
so they go okay all right all right
you know we realized there's no free
lunch and so we go for freedom itself
and they go through and then they find
out that freedom itself a certain price
called responsibility you're supposed to
take care of yourself is just to solve
your own problems well everybody hates
solving their own problems
and along comes somebody and says hey a
free problem-solving over here you know
and they go back to after all you know
if human beings had had a capacity to to
learn these lessons easily the a Ponzi
scheme would have only worked once with
mr. Ponzi right but here's mr. Madoff it
works over and over again Social
Security and Social Security the largest
Ponzi scheme ever yeah you're one of the
most quotable guys around and one quote
that I attribute to you or have for a
long time is something the effect of the
job of a president is to stand around
for four years and take credit for
anything good that happens is that
really I mean is this play set for sure
if I said Debra I'm saying it now is it
even Republicans do Democrats do it of
course Obama's doing it this job
creation hocus-pocus is it really just
back to the time when we were primitive
tribesmen and we killed the king if we
had a bad crop yield and we praise the
king if we had a great harvest isn't
back to that time
always been that time I mean we look to
political leadership for all sorts of
things to put if the leadership can't
possibly deliver and we we just bless
them you know I mean when we had a
walkover in the Gulf War in 1991 we just
couldn't have been happier with what
George Bush was senior George Bush he is
is he had 110 percent approval ratings
like a month later we go into recession
and we're ready to slaughter the guy I
mean we throw them overboard in favor of
this bozo from Arkansas the world's most
unpleasant marriage and and Rovin hands
besides you know and and it's had you go
and you start to realize that the real
job of a conservative the real job of
libertarian the real job of people who
are in favor of individual freedom and
individual responsibility is not to back
one side or back the other side is to
convince people to back away from
politics government and politics is
therefore very very limited purposes
they're just a few things that we need
from the political system we do need a
rule of law we do need protection from
external enemies we need to protect them
from each other when we misbehave which
is the rule of law and you know to some
extent because this is always true with
governments even no matter how pure
libertarian one is you have to realize
that the government does provide help to
people in catastrophic circumstances
something like Katrina
if city floods government is supposed to
come help you bail you know I mean
there's no doubt about that but that's
it for government they help us in other
catastrophes when we're completely
incapable of helping ourselves they
defend us from external enemies and they
defend us from internal enemies they've
got a legal monopoly on deadly force and
and that's and that's it and when we
start to ask them for also would you
make sure that our food has no trans
fats and my shoes don't fit and could
you get me a better haircut you know
that's you know a couple of things first
place they'll say yes because they love
power they're bad people people who go
into politics are bad people
let's just face it secondly they're not
going to do a good job at this stuff
because you can't task an organization
with that many duties and expect them to
do all of them or even any of them well
so it's self-defeating on a couple of
different levels people will use your
requests to grab power from you and they
will also do a damn bad job